un bon soir nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 60,18
bienvenue dans cette édition du lundi 28
septembre voici les titres
il est le nouveau député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines le maire de
bois d'arcy philippe benassaya s'est
imposé hier contre sandrine grand gang
lors du second tour de la législative
partielle
un scrutin qui a vu le retour du vieux
clivage droite-gauche réaction à suivre
l'émotion hier à guyancourt pour cette
messe en l'église du cap-saint-jacques
une cérémonie de souvenir se tenait pour
les défunts du colis 19 et pour leurs
familles elle qui n'ont pas pu faire le
deuil de leurs proches disparus au plus
fort de la crise sanitaire
et puis c'est un problème récurrent dans
le département les dépôts sauvages
comment lutter contre ce phénomène
c'était l'objet d'une table ronde au
bréviaire qui a réuni vendredi
élus et responsables yvelinois dans le
même temps les agriculteurs se
mobilisaient sur le sujet à rambouillet
présentation également tout à l'heure de
100 solutions à la rentrée un forum
d'orientation et d'insertion
socioprofessionnelle au programme ce
mercredi 7 à montigny le bretonneux
[Musique]
je vous le disais dans les titres et les
électeurs de la 11e circonscription des
yvelines étaient appelés aux urnes hier
pour élire leur nouveau aux députés
après la démission de nadia est rentré
au gouvernement
et c'est philippe benassaya le maire de
bois d'arcy qui a remporté ce second
tour et les précisions de marie pas
neutre à et de nicolas landry second
tour de la législative partielle dans la
12e circonscription des yvelines marquée
par un taux de participation de 15,3
pour cent
philippe benassaya maire de bois d'arcy
il faisait face à sandrine grand gang
adjointe au maire de trappes
ils l'emportent avec 57,63 % des
suffrages exprimés
il quitte son poste de maire de bois
d'arcy afin de remplir ses fonctions de
député yvelinois une grande émotion
grande fierté d'abord pour le l'ampleur
du résultat
malgré une faible participation cette
fois ci on aura vraiment un député
présent qui sillonnera sa
circonscription comme un conseiller
départemental sillonne son canton donc
c'est un petit peu la même chose la même
formation
la même façon de faire un député proche
des français prose est proche des
attentes
et puis aussi un député qui porte des
valeurs de son côté sandrine grand gambe
rappelle qu'à la dernière élection
législatives la gauche n'avait pas
réussi à se qualifier sa réaction face
au résultat est mitigé
réactions contrastées se dire que à la
fois vraie déception de voir que les
ses lecteurs de la 11e circonscription
se sont massivement abstenus malgré nos
appels à la mobilisation et en même
temps des satisfaction de voir des beaux
scores attrape le signe que il ya une
forme d'adhésion au travail que l'on
mène depuis maintenant trois mois la
circonscription n'avait pas été
remportée par la droite depuis la
défaite de jean michel fourgous en 2012
face à benoit une belle transmission
puisque en fait dans les résultats vous
avez aujourd'hui six communes sur sept
qui soutiennent donc nos idées ne l'est
donc notre candidat je veux dire que
c'est une belle victoire et puis c'est
des bonnes conditions de transmission
on vient de doubler le nombre de nos
députés dans le département donc c'est
considérable je rappelle que ce
département qui avait compté jusqu'à
douze députés de la majorité
présidentielle lorsque nous étions
pouvoir dans l'opposition à monsieur
macro nous n'avons fait élire qu'un seul
député le maire de bois d'arcy devrait
être remplacé par jean philippe plus
actuel adjoint aux finances et aux
affaires scolaires et pour parler de ce
scrutin avec - visioconférence sophie
primas bonsoir
bon ça à sénatrice à l'est républicain
des ivy nous est également
vice-présidente de la fédération
l est républicain dans le département
déjà quel regard portez-vous sur le
résultat de ce scrutin la victoire de
philippe benassaya dans la 11e
circonscription
or ben écoutez c'est une victoire qui
fait du bien de voir qui est porteuse
d'espoir or nous qui souhaitons un
carnet en fait l'alternative à emmanuel
macron en 2022 et donc c'est un symbole
un premier un premier pas qui est tout à
fait intéressant on a perdu la vidéo
avec vous c'est bon vous a récupéré
sophie primas vous dites c'est
intéressant
dans une 11e circonscription voilà qui
passent de droite à gauche de gauche à
droite jean michel fourgous était dépité
jusqu'en 2012 c'est benoît hamon ensuite
qui a été député de 2012 à 2017 nadia
pour la république en marge de 2017 à
2020 où il récupérer cette
circonscription c'est un pas important
dans la reconstruction de la droite au
niveau local oui bien sûr c'est un pas
important dans la reconstruction de la
droite avec dire et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que l'on voit
réapparaître d'ailleurs d'autres sujets
sans enjeux là dit une dichotomie entre
la gauche et la droite qui existent
elles existent nationalement il existe
dans ce département vous faites bien de
souligner que sa circonscription qui
voilà qui alterne de temps en temps mais
avec systématiquement des personnes et
des personnages qui portent des
convictions extrêmement fortes
c'était le cas par exemple de benoît
hamon c'était le cas bien sûr de jean
michel fourgous qui était emblématique
de cette circonscription
et puis et bien aux dernières
législatives j'allais dire que tout ça a
volé en éclats avec la vague macro ni
c'est là qu'en marche on voit qu'il ne
reste pas grand chose de cette vague et
que les français ont besoin dhr ont des
fondamentaux mais c'est une politique de
troie qui s'oppose pas de place aux
extrêmes
vous voyez oui vous ce retour du clivage
gauche droite après vous l'avez dit une
vague en marche qui a été perceptible en
2007 après l'élection d' emmanuel macron
et la république en marche et son allié
du modem avait remporté onze des douze
circonscription des yvelines là on
revient à des schémas politiques on va
dire un peu plus classique
oui je crois dans le climat politique
qui est le nôtre aujourd'hui on voit
bien que la république en marché
notamment sur les territoires beaucoup
de mal à vaincre
on le voit ici dans cette 9e
circonscription je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de dire qu'on l'a vu
également au sénat hier ou sur la moitié
des départements on a vu alors que notre
groupe est républicain était déjà le
groupe majoritaire était déjà très
puissant au sénat et bien ce groupe
s'est renforcée parce que au-delà de la
bulle médiatique sur les grandes
métropoles dans les territoires vous
car véritablement la voix de cette
france des territoires et de la france
de l'expérience du pragmatisme et de la
proximité donc fait la transition sophie
primas j'allais justement aborder cette
thématique des sénatoriales la moitié
des sièges n'y a pas de souci la moitié
des sièges du sénat est effectivement
renouvelé dimanche c'est à dire 172
sièges dans 63 départements 58
départements de la métropole 5
d'outre-mer les yvelines n'étaient pas
concernés par ce scrutin mais voilà je
précise que ce sont les grands électeurs
en particulier les mères mais pas qu'eux
qui votait la droite et le centre vous
l'avez dit un conservent leur majorité
dans la haute chambre 76 sièges qui sont
renouvelés il ya aussi une dizaine de
sièges supplémentaires gérard larcher va
donc conserver aussi un son poste de
président du sénat est-ce que ça va
permettre au sénat de continuer ce rôle
de contre-pouvoir qu'il a vis-à-vis de
l'état oui parfaitement c'est un petit
peu dans le même esprit de ce que je
disais tout à l'heure en fait le sénat
est indispensable dans l' équilibre
polydor c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que le
général de gaulle l'avait souhaité dans
la constitution de 58 comme étant autre
chose que la chambre de la pulsion du
peuple qui est-ce qui est l'assemblée
nationale le sénat et pour être est là
pour être un balancier 1 et pour avoir
un rôle d' équilibre politique un
contre-pouvoir qui n'est pas comme le
dit souvent gérard larcher un anti
pouvoir et d'ailleurs nous votons un
certain nombre de textes
nous avons voté l'urgence nous avons
voté un texte sur le logement n'ont pas
qu'il nous paraissait m'en aller dans
votre sens
mais parce que nous y avions apporté des
améliorations notamment dans les coupes
des territoires qui nous paraissaient
extrêmement important deuxième chambre
qui est - la chambre des pus politique
des français qui est des territoires et
des élus
elle a un rôle de stabilisateur et rôle
de contre-pouvoir qui est bien
nécessaire parce qu'on ne peut pas
laisser un parti avoir toutes les cartes
en main c'est impossible
la droite qui confirme leur assise au
sénat y aussi la présence des verts qui
se renforce avec la constitution d'un
groupe est ce que vous attendez un
travail constructif avec avec vous vos
compatriotes des verts alors le travail
constructif c'est la marque du sénat on
essaye et toujours et moi comme
présidente de commission j'essaye
d'avoir un travail collectif constructif
jusqu'au bout mais il ya un fait
majoritaire et parfois nous avons des
écarts avec les écologistes nous avons
des écarts ils vont s'exprimer assez
rapidement dans les prochaines semaines
je veux juste dire que sur la poussée
écologique naturellement comme les
départements dans lesquels les grandes
métropoles pratique comme lyon bordeaux
et est renouvelable et donc comme ces
villes ont passé son pastis ou dany
europe ecologie les verts
eh bien on a six nouveaux sénateurs
écologistes mais les autres étaient déjà
élus étaient dispersés dans d'autres
groupes politiques car ils ne pouvaient
pas former un groupe donc il ya pas de
12 nouveaux sénateurs écologique on a à
peu près la moitié est effectivement ils
peuvent reconstituer le groupe qui
s'était dissout aux dernières élections
merci sophie primas d'avoir été avec
nous avec plaisir mais je précise je
rappelle que vous êtes sénatrice les
républicains des yvelines est également
vice-présidente de la fédération les
républicains dans le département dans
l'actualité forcément aussi l'épidémie
de kovy de 19 les yvelines sont placés
depuis quelques jours en zone d' alerte
comme toute la grande couronne
francilienne par le gouvernement paris
et la petite couronne sont tels en zone
d' alerte renforcée dans les faits pour
les yvelines dans le 78 cela se traduit
par l'interdiction des rassemblements
festifs ou familiaux les comme les
anniversaires mais aussi les mariages à
des rassemblement festifs qui doivent
être limités à 30 personnes 30 personnes
maximum on peut pas aller au delà de
cette barre des 30 personnes dans les
établissements recevant du public
c'est une mesure qui est entrée en
vigueur ce matin par arrêté du préfet
des yvelines jean jacques gouin a
également prolongé l'obligation du port
du masque pour les plus de 11 ans autour
des gares et des écoles dans un rayon de
50 mètres
cette disposition était déjà en place
depuis début septembre et donc étendu au
moins jusqu'à la fin octobre une
nouvelle mesure donc dans un département
les chiffres de l'épidémie sont à la
hausse d'après les dernière
donné que nous avons depuis vendredi le
taux d'incidence est passé à 107,14 un
taux d'incidence à 107,14 la semaine
d'avant il était de 74 un taux de
positivité vous allez le voir qui va
s'afficher dans un instant qui est
également en augmentation il s'établit
désormais à 9 56% du côté de la tension
hospitalière en revanche ça se stabilise
après une progression constante observée
depuis début septembre
194 personnes étaient hospitalisées hier
c'est une d'au moins 24 heures elle 23
patients étaient toujours en réanimation
dans les hôpitaux yvelinois la crise
sanitaire qui au plus fort avait
contraint le gouvernement a placé le
pays dans un confinement pour de
nombreux français il était donc
difficile de faire le deuil d'un proche
disparu avec des obsèques qui ont été
parfois repousser de six mois
ce samedi à vue en cours une messe en
hommage au défunt aux disparus étaient
organisées le reportage à ce sujet de
mélanie poquet de justin brasier dire
enfin au revoir pour beaucoup de ses
paroissiens set mais c'était attendu
pour commencer à faire son deuil des
enfants des conjoints des amis une
centaine de personnes s'est rassemblée
ce samedi en l'église du
cap-saint-jacques c'est le mot
consolation qui me vient vraiment
c'était une très belle célébration et on
s'est sentis consoler elle était
croyante
donc il était important qu'avec son fils
qui est venu nous soyons aujourd'hui
rassemblés pour en quelque sorte
compenser ce manque d'obsèques et
honorer sa mémoire
on a pu lui dire au revoir par whatsapp
uniquement donc on a été un petit peu
privé de
privé des derniers moments de deux
mamans dauphin de notre maire et
heureusement elle avait à ses côtés ma
belle fille qui est médecin gériatre et
et mon fils une messe pensée est
célébrée par pierre hervé grosjean
marquée par les blessures de ses
paroissiens c'est vrai que les
conditions extrêmement durs qu'on a
connus n'ont pas permis justement à
beaucoup de gens de pouvoir vivre ces
moments difficiles de la mort d'un
proche dans la tendresse nécessaire dans
la dans l'accompagnement dans la dans la
consolation dans la proximité avec ses
proches
tout ça ils ont été privés et je crois
qu'il qu'il était temps de d'essayer un
peu de réparer ça elle la paroisse
montini voisins le bretonneux à célébrer
37 obsèques pendant les deux mois de
confinement depuis le 1er juin les
cérémonies funéraires ne sont plus
limités à 20 personnes
cet élément nouveau pour la maison
centrale de poissy le ministre de la
justice eric dupond moretti a adressé un
courrier au maire de la commune il se
dit favorable à l'ouverture d'un
dialogue constructif concernant
l'établissement pénitentiaire pour
rappel le maire karl olive milite depuis
plusieurs années pour le déménagement de
la prison située en centre ville ils
dénoncent la vétusté des lieux datant du
xviie siècle en mars 2010neuf rappelez
vous un mur d'enceinte du site s'est
écroulé à la maison centrale abrite
environ 190 détenus trop de déchets dans
les champs et dans les chemins communaux
c'est un phénomène de plus en plus
visibles dans les yvelines associations
agriculteurs et élus ont décidé de se
mobiliser
elle dénonce ces associations il dénonce
aussi ses élus ses dépôts sauvages et
tente d'apporter des solutions patrick
jacques de dixmude michael et demi
d'euros et astrid bergère les
agriculteurs n'en peuvent plus les
dépôts sauvages se multiplient dans les
champs et les chemins communaux
rassemblées dans divers points d'île de
france vendredi 25 septembre et zouk
déverser les déchets qu'ils découvrent
au quotidien plus déchetteries sont
payantes pour les artisans et les
horaires d'ouverture sont enfin voila
c'est un peu compliqué quand sa ferme à
15h ou que c'est pas ouvert tous les
jours des gens plutôt que deux
de les emmener en déchetterie de
s'emmerder il est temps mais nous les
déposa où il ya de la place quoi et donc
dans nos champs ou dans les chemins
communaux et notamment il ya des fois où
il ya des communes qui demandent à ce
que ça soit carrément les paysans qu'ils
enlèvent alors que c'est sur des
endroits communaux face à ce phénomène
élus autorités et associations de
protection de l'environnement se sont
d'ailleurs réunis la même journée pour
trouver des solutions il faut évidemment
continuer à faire des actions de
pédagogie des actions de prévention dès
le plus jeune âge mais qu'au delà et
variées des sanctions effectives aussi
qu'ils puissent être mises en place
donc l'idée c'est de se confronter
aujourd'hui de faire échanger ensemble
tous ceux qui concourent à notre
territoire à la vie du territoire pour
voir ce qui mériterait d'être amélioré
pour le moment les personnes qui
déversent leurs déchets peuvent recevoir
des amendes
bruno myle yens le député des yvelines
veut aller encore plus loin qu'il faut
effectivement mettre des mesures encore
plus coercitives
là on va jusqu'à la saisie du véhicule
qui me paraît être
importantes comme mesure parce que
souvent la simple amende ne suffit pas
où les gens m'ont par les moyens de la
payer
autre élément évoqué la création d'une
véritable filière de recyclage des
déchets du bâtiment
l'idée serait que les artisans puissent
déposer leurs déchets dans des endroits
dédiés gratuitement c'est une réalité à
chaque rentrée encore plus cette année
avec l'épidémie de coronavirus beaucoup
de jeunes se retrouvent sans projet
validé ou sans formation c'est pour les
aiguiller quête organisée mercredi sans
solution à la rentrée un forum proposé
par la ville de montigny le bretonneux
avec yveline information jeunesse et au
gymnase pierre de coubertin présentation
en interview express
[Musique]
les objectif c'est d'apporter un soutien
un accompagnement aux jeunes qui sont en
difficulté à la rentrée c'est en général
une problématique rencontrée chaque
année mais c'est encore plus difficile
pour certains avec la crise actuelle
[Musique]
oui c'est compliqué parce que les
entreprises ont peu de visibilité sur
sur leurs possibilités d'embauché ont
elles-mêmes des difficultés à maintenir
leur équipe en place donc intégrer deux
des jeunes
qu'ils sortent des études ou qui
recherchent une alternance un stage
c'est un petit peu compliqué pour elle
alors sur ce forum il y aura 45 stands
avec 35 recruteurs et parmi ces
recruteurs y aura donc des possibilités
en termes d'alternance d'emplois de
stages et de service civique
il y aura également un mur d'offres et
des structures d'accompagnement et
d'information pour les jeunes jour que
faire connaître l'accompagnant qu'elles
peuvent proposer aux jeunes et aussi
cerné un petit peu plus un projet qui
pourrait les aiguilles et s'ils sont
complètement perdus dans leurs leurs
perspectives de d'insertion on va dire
et je précise que le port du masque sera
obligatoire sur place rendez vous de 14
heures à 18 heures mercredi c'est au
gymnase pierre de coubertin à montigny
le bretonneux le sport il avait évolué
dans les yvelines entre 2011 et 2012 au
sein de l'équipe cycliste de l'armée
basées à saint-germain-en-laye julian
alaphilippe monte sur le toit du monde à
l'athlète de 28 ans a décroché hier le
titre de champion du monde de cyclisme
sur route à imola en italie
il est le premier français à être sacré
depuis 1997 et la victoire de laurent
brochard et julian alaphilippe que nous
avons croisé à plusieurs reprises sur
les routes yvelinoise notamment celle du
paris nice et justement il y avait du
cyclisme
hier aussi dans les yvelines la
cinquième édition du grand prix à
cycliste de montigny se tenait ce
dimanche dans la commune avec une
cinquantaine de coureurs sur la ligne de
départ mickaël ennemis doro et justine
brasier le vent et la pluie ne les ont
pas découragés une cinquantaine de
cyclistes au lieu des 150 inscrits est
venu ce dimanche 27 septembre sur la
ligne de départ pour participer au 5e
grand prix cycliste de montigny et
l'épreuve prévue initialement au
printemps cette journée est journée
id non prévus là pour encore remercier
les courageux qui sont enlevés ce matin
à deux bonnes heures pour venir faire
une course sous la pluie et dans le vent
mais c'est un peu parti de fait partie
du métier de coureur cycliste
les cours de 18 à 50 ans ont réalisé 26
tours de 3 km pour un total de 78 km à
la fin de l'épreuve les organisateurs
avaient bloqué plusieurs rues de
montigny le bretonneux pour créer un
parcours atypique pour les sportifs gros
plombs parce que les routes sont larges
on sait relativement plat est la grosse
difficulté c'est la montée de nicolas
bour
suivant le sens du vent s'ils vont
pousser coureurs c'est facile s'il est
dans l'otan c'est difficile cette
édition 2020 permis à un coureur de
montigny le bretonneux de s'illustrer
romain bardet homonyme du célèbre
coureur français devenu le premier
sportif du club a remporté ce grand prix
une nouvelle édition sera programmée
l'année prochaine les organisateurs
espèrent cette fois ci l'organiser au
printemps et toute l'actualité sportive
les résultats du week-end à retrouver
dans un instant l'émission le 7-8 sport
présentée par michael elle me d'euros
c'est à partir de 18h30
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]